بالارقام نتعرف كيف تؤثر مباريات
المونديال بحسب استطلاع موقع دلتايلند
سبعه 77 بالمئه من موظفين فقط الخليج
يخططون لمشاهده بعض المباريات على اقل
تقدير ايضا واحد واربعون بالمئه من
الموظفين في دول الخليج المشاركين في نفس
الاستطلاع يخططون لمشاهده المباريات اثناء
ساعات العمل
16% من الموظفين المشاركين بالاستطلاع
خطته ويخططون ايضا للسفر من اجل المتابعه
مباريات كاس العالم في قطر واحد من كل سته
اشخاص من المشاركين في الاستطلاع قالوا
بانهم سيشاهدون المباريات سرا اثناء العمل
عبر الانترنت المباشر على كل حال من
الاردن سالنا الناس هل يؤثر المونديال على
امتيال انتاجاتكم في العمل فالق انه
[موسيقى]
طبعا بعد اربع سنوات
لازم تحضر بس المباريات اللي فيها فرق لها
قدره علينا يعني الفريق بيلعب كويس
[موسيقى]
والله المونديال الاثر في طريقه سلبيه
تعرف كل يوم او كل يوم بعد يوم يكون في
مباريات وكل يوم بكون في حوالي خمس ست
مباريات يعني ليكون مباراه بتاخذ منك ثلاث
ساعات
ثلاث مثلا خمسه 15 ساعه اذا كنت متابع
يعني بشكل كبير والله الصراحه اكثر نسبه
كبيره على الشعب وعلى كل الناس يعني كل
الصراحه همم
يعني بشكل عام هو راح يؤثر على الكل اكيد
المباراه